[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter et échanger sur les sujets qui
font l'actualité
à partir d'aujourd'hui mercredi 20
janvier les lycéens commencent à
formuler leurs voeux pour des formations
supérieures sur parcours sur une période
pas toujours facile mais après un nom
d'enseignement en présentiel ou au
virtuel
l'orientation est elle plus difficile
cette année on en parle pendant les
prochaines uteq nous inviter ariane des
pierres fihri vous êtes directrice de la
rédaction de l'étudiant bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir à tous les auditeurs et lætitia
nico administratrice de la fcpe 78
l'association de parents d'élèves
bonsoir bonsoir à tous alors difficultés
à se projeter à faire le tri dans les
nombreuses formations proposées
l'orientation scolaire et chaque année
un moment de stress pour de nombreux
lycéens et étudiants laetitia n'est que
je vais commencer avec vous est ce que
c'est vrai ou est ce que c'est un cliché
que parfois l'orientation et c'est un
moment difficile alors l'orientation
c'est effectivement quelque chose de
difficile pour les jeunes c'est pas un
cliché c'est une chose que l'on doit
réfléchir longtemps à l'avancé avec
toute leur organisation du bac
souvent les élèves de seconde sont
amenés à y réfléchir beaucoup plus tôt
qu'auparavant cette année avec cette
pandémie
les familles sont moins présentes dans
les établissements elles ont moins de
liens avec les enseignants donc c'est
pas toujours très facile ariane des
pierres ferry avant de cette situation
très inédite de l'aco vide
quels étaient les préoccupations des
jeunes la distance la meilleure
formation
une question de budget alors je dirais
que le pour assurer un peu notre
auditeur de l'orientation c'est une
démarche d'interrogations et qui
comporte une part d'incertitude
puisqu'on face vers l'avenir et qu'on ne
sait pas encore de quoi il sera fait
donc l'orientation
elle vise à baliser un petit cet avenir
et à trouver des voies qui progresse
pondre à chacun donc comme vous le
disiez on peut la voir
on peut avoir une vocation comme une
idée précise qu'en huit faire et là
c'est le fly d'abord idéal ensuite il
peut y en avoir la préoccupation de la
proximité clope mans avec éventuel
accord resté dans la même région que ses
parents ou l'envi d'être exploré
d'autres d'autres lieux ensuite on peut
être beaucoup moins déterminés et là
évidemment toute la démarche
d'information et d'interrogations sur
soi même aussi j'y reviens l'orientation
c'est d'abord se connaître soi-même et
réfléchir à ce que l'on aime ou selon
elle n'aime pas c'est aussi une
indication
parfois on ne sait pas du tout mon
univers mais en revanche on sait ce
qu'on m'a pas du tout envie de faire et
ça c'est une première liste alors dans
un article du monde daté du 18 janvier
des psychologues de l'éducation
nationale explique d'avoir jamais eu
autant d'élèves anxieux quant à leur
orientation
laetitia nico est ce que c'est ce que
vous remontent aussi certains parents
d'élèves ou que vous rencontrez vous
même
ah oui au niveau de la fcpe il ya
beaucoup de parents d'élèves qui se
posent des questions
parce que comme disait madame des
pierres ferry c'est une analyse de soi
même pour savoir où est-ce qu'on veut
être ont été ce qu'on veut choisir comme
formule
avant il y avait beaucoup de dialogues
on pouvait aller aux différentes portes
ouvertes au niveau des grandes écoles ou
même quand on voulait aller au lycée on
pouvait faire des mini stages dans des
établissements avec cette pandémie
ça n'existe plus a pour l'instant
espérons que ça revienne mais les femmes
y sont forcées wii sont inquiètes elles
zen au mieux leurs jeunes parce que
c'est pas une procédure facile mais
c'est très anxiogène avec ses problèmes
effectivement alors je vous propose
maintenant d'écouter le témoignage d'un
parent d'élève aussi pep conflans sainte
honorine
le fils de cécile river est en terminale
générale au lycée charles de gaulle de
poissy
pour le moment c'est très difficile de
le mobiliser sur l'orientation ont la
bonne et simple raison qu'avec la
réforme du bac justement les premières
épreuves de spécialités vont être les 15
16 et 17 mars
ce qui fait que là précisément à l'heure
où on se parle il est en épreuve blanche
ont le bac
donc évidemment pour lui la priorité
c'est déjà ça
[Musique]
c'est très compliqué de pouvoir se
projeter alors que l'on ne peut avoir
des informations que de façon
dématérialisée
on a eu
moi j'ai insisté l'année dernière pour
aller sur des salons locaux de
l'orientation en l'occurrence le plus
proche de chez nous c'est cergy donc
alors qu'il était en première
[Musique]
harcourt sud ouvre aujourd'hui il y sera
ouvert jusqu'au 11 mars
donc il n'ya pas de pression non plus
pas encore mais quand bien même il ya
certaines hésitent et qui doivent faire
leur chemin dans la tête de chacun des
lycéens savoir si potentiellement on
peut se retrouver dans une formation à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de la
maison surtout en ce moment avec quand
on voit l'état d'aider des étudiants qui
sont livrés à eux mêmes dans des
conditions compliquées
on réfléchit à deux fois quand même
alors l'étudiant réaliser un
questionnaire dont les résultats ont été
publiés aujourd'hui 47% des candidats
sont stressés 17 très stressée rien des
pierres fihri est ce que l'étudiant a
aussi durant cette période de co2 19
modifier ces contenus est ce qu'on
cherche plus s'arracher à rassurer ou
est-ce qu'on vous êtes encore plus
sollicité que les années précédentes
en fait cette crise est là encore plus
conforté notre ligne éditoriale qui est
celle de l'information et du conseil
avec des éléments qui sont à la fois
très pratique où on va expliquer les
filières on va proposer aussi des quizz
sur notre site pour pouvoir se tester un
suspect pour telle ou telle filière pour
tel ou tel métier
donc ça permet d'entrevoir aussi déjà ce
que va ce que vont être ses filières et
si on peut il correspondre
et puis on a aussi toute une série
d'articles de vidéos de podcasts ou on
rentre dans le détail j'allais dire que
chacune des filières ont fait témoigner
des jeunes gens ou des professeurs on
donne tous les détails aussi des
différentes étapes de l'orientation elle
soit précédemment tout au long du lycée
et même dès le collège et ensuite au
moment de l'ouverture de parcours sup
mais je dirais que on parlait tout à
l'heure un petit peu du fait que les
élèves sont stressés ils sont stressés
habituellement à cette période de
l'année ils ne sont encore plus
aujourd'hui évidemment du fait des
différentes incertitudes
il se présente pour tout le monde en
réalité et également par rapport à
demain et c'est vrai que vous avez vues
dans le dans le questionnaire qu'on a
adressé à nos lecteurs on a leur a aussi
demandé comment il se projetait
vis-à-vis de la rentrée universitaire et
la rentrée l'université alors fait peur
aussi à l'aune de ce qu'il voit
aujourd'hui dans différentes formations
et on le voit aujourd'hui avec une
manifestation d'étudiants dans les rues
de paris alors je ne sais pas s'il y
avait eu d'autres et d'autres villes qui
étaient mobilisés mais ils seront
également aux côtés des enseignants et
des lycéens le 26 donc effectivement ce
mal être et ce sentiment d'isolement la
précarité aussi liées aux aspects
économiques 1 le job étudiant est
beaucoup plus difficile à trouver bien
entendu donc en fait ya aussi cette
projection dans l'avenir qui est plus
difficile quand on voit ses pairs ils
sont aujourd'hui en classe et manifeste
chez nous pas en classe d'ailleurs c'est
bien le problème et manifestent leurs
difficultés et leurs interrogations
il était celle ci est ce que il faut pas
à rassurer les parents rappeler aussi
qu'on a le droit à l'erreur une année ce
n'est peut-être qu'une année de perdue
dans des études qui nous ne
correspondait pas alors nous dans notre
réseau fcpe on accueille tous les
parents des enfants qui sans classes
d'orientation notre réseau nous permet
de se rassurent nous permet de se
rassurer entre nous de donner des
informations chacun peut partager à ce
niveau-là ça sert à sion
je voudrais rebondir sur ce qu'a dit
madame des pierres ferry c'est que
l'état psychologique des jeunes en
première année soit d'université
souhaite différentes écoles est
effectivement difficile et beaucoup de
parents se posent la question si ça va
pas venir à nouveau alourdi repart
consul cette année parce que ceux qui
sont en première année peuvent revenir
sur par conçu pour proposer des voeux et
ça c'est un cas elle parce qu'on se dit
qu'il y aura un grand un plus grand
nombre que d'habitude de d'étudiants qui
vont vouloir redemander des parcours en
études supérieures et sa cinquième ou
les familles qui sont en terminale
on sait aussi que on a pu
donc le baccalauréat avait été donné
l'année dernière pourraient être donnés
cette année
est ce qu'il ya un sentiment madame nico
d'une dévalorisation de ses futurs
candidats qu'ils n'iraient pas dans des
filières auxquels ils pourraient avoir
droit
alors donnez le baccalauréat l'année
dernière ça très dommage pour les jeunes
qui sont dans cette tranche d'âge cela
doit leur faire extrêmement de paix moi
j'ai mon garçon qui a passé son bac
l'année dernière il a pas eu parce qu'on
lui a donné il a beaucoup travaillé pour
la rencontre continue c'est difficile
non moi pour moi il n'a pas été donné ne
sera pas encore donné cette année je
pense pas parce que le contrôle continu
un travail régulier de la part des
élèves ceux qui travaillent ils vont
pouvoir avoir des bonnes notes et ceux
qui sont en difficulté il faut être là
pour les aider pour les soutenir et
c'est de retrouver la meilleure
formation qui leur correspondent c'est
ça le plus important
aucun ferry ces quelques lignes aussi
qu'on vous a remonté c'est ce sentiment
d'être dévalorisés alors cette
dévalorisation au moment où le bac a été
donc transformé enfin transformer ou a
été annoncé le fait que ce serait les
notes de contrôle continu qui seraient
prises en compte
on a effectivement arrivé différents
lycéens qui nous disait que il avait
cette peur un petit peu eux sur leur cv
dans quelques années si on met 6 soit
indiquée bakhan et de pizzas alors
maintenant on va pouvoir parler
peut-être de 2021 mais des choses ne
sont pas dites
il n'avait pas que ça puisse dévalorisé
cela dit je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec madame nico il faut arrêter deux
tiers qu'il a été donné on apprend parle
d'un contrôle continu
les élèves travaillent vont travailler
l'année d'avant c'est à dire en première
il est évident que les commissions qui
ont harmonisé les notes mais comme c'est
le cas à l'issue des épreuves également
alors s'il ya eu une tolérance
franchement elle n'a pas concerné
l'ensemble et des lycéens ont déjà ça
c'est le premier point en revanche pour
revenir sur votre question sur la
réorientation la réorientation elle est
possible chaque ami sûr par fonction
c'est à dire que les élèves qui sont les
étudiants qui sont en première année
preuve s'il le souhaite demander une
réorientation il ya aussi un phénomène
en augmentation en milieu d'année pour
entrez dans des cursus au second
semestre donc là on n'a pas encore le
détail deux est ce que c'est un
phénomène d'augmentation
et est ce qu'il le sera l'année
prochaine on sera au mois de septembre
ou un peu plus tard dans l'année avec
les chiffres finaux de parcours occupe
en revanche on peut anticiper que
certains aient envie de se réorienter
parce que ils ont fait un choix rapide
l'année dernière parce qu'ils
s'attendaient pas à voir le bas classé
pour la la la la petite frange de
population qui peut être été un peu
limité a été favorisée par le contrôle
continu
mais ça ne concerne qu'une petite
proportion est effectivement les
conditions d'étude cette année peuvent
avoir donné envie à certains de choisir
un autre type d'établissement ou de
formation parce qu'ils ne se sont pas
sentis à l'aise où ils n'ont pas réussi
en fait tout simplement dans cette
filière en étudiant à distance alors ce
début d'année c'est aussi à l'époque des
journées portes ouvertes crise sanitaire
oblige de nombreux rendez-vous sont sur
inscription ou en digital ont fait un
petit état des lieux sur saint quentin
en yvelines
le 23 janvier l'école d'ingénieurs
estaca et l'école de l'audiovisuel
troisième organisent leur journée portes
ouvertes en virtuel du côté de piger
performance et en présentiel présentiel
aussi pour le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité à
guyancourt pour les écoles de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de paris
ile-de-france l'université versailles
saint quentin et l'institut de formation
en soins infirmiers de la mgen à la
verrière le rendez vous se fera en ligne
c'est une liste bien sûr non exhaustive
il ne faut pas hésiter à se rendre sur
les différents sites internet des lieux
de formation
le digital c'est aussi pour les salons
un rendez vous incontournable ariane des
pierres ferry l'étudiant a donc fait le
choix nasa lyon d'un salon entièrement
digitalisé en ligne comment est ce que
vous l'avez penser ce salon alors le
premier salon berger qu'on a pensé on la
pensait au mois de juin dernier
donc c'est pour vous dire que c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on travaille
depuis longtemps alors quand on pense un
salon virtuel
on a évidemment nos marques et
d'ailleurs en tant que leader des salons
de l'orientation l'étudiant à une
expérience qui est une connaissance des
salons alors on va lui dire physiquement
parce que maintenant on différencie les
deux
on s'est appuyé sur cette expérience là
et on a aussi essayé d'imaginer quelque
chose qui soit différent parce qu'en
réalité aujourd'hui la démarche
d'information
elle est différente il faut trouver de
nouvelles ressources et il faut se
mettre dans de nouvelles postures
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui doit
aussi rassurer on a nos auditeurs ce
soir c'est normal d'être un petit peu
perdues parce qu on fait différemment
cette année donc les ressources il faut
les trouver ailleurs et autrement et
existe et notamment sur les salons
virtuels alors pourquoi les salons qu'un
tour de france c'est ce qui va concerner
d'autres éditions ce soir il ouvre
demain et nous aurons trois jours deux
temps forts alors comment ça se passe
mais vous avez des exposants qui sont là
comme sur un salon classique
ils sont un sport virtuel sur lequel
vous pouvez la foi entrent en contact
avec eux et posé plus cocasse no vous
pouvez prendre des rendez-vous ou
demander à être contacté ultérieurement
vous pouvez y consulter de la
documentation des vidéos comme surtout
salon de l'étudiant vous avez des
conférences éditorial dans lesquels on
va décrypter différence dans le jeu et
filières d'orientation qui sont connus
en live donc vous pouvez poser vos
questions qui comme dans la dans la
vraie vie et ensuite ça c'est l'
avantage aussi de ce salon qui est
virtuel c'est que la plateforme puisque
elle est ouverte sur plusieurs semaines
concurrente la durée de parcours tueur
là ce serait tout ce qu'on appelait à
janvier pour ce qui concerne le salon
d'île de france selon des équipes et en
ile de france
et bien en fait vous aurez accès encore
aux exposants et sachant que ce salon
virtuel il est comme d'habitude on les
salons de l'étudiant monté en
partenariat avec tout et secteur de
l'eau relations institutionnelles qui
sont impliqués pour ce qui concerne la
france on à la ville de bertal de 51 en
ce qui vous concerne puisque dans votre
votre département on à la région avait
toute la région le 17 le seuil haut
enfin donc tous les retrouve tous les
acteurs habituels avec des coûts de mise
en relation et de contacts et bien
qu'ils sont virtuelles mais qu'ils
peuvent aussi belle à nous sommes en
train de discuter par caméras
interposées
eh bien vous pourrez le faire sur notre
salon également et c'est la même chose
et journée portes ouvertes que vous
évoquez
les établissements se sont mis en ordre
de marche pour entrer en contact et
notre manière laetitia nikon justement
ce digital comment est ce qu'il est vécu
par les lycéens les étudiants ou les
parents est-ce que c'est plus facile
d'accéder aux informations ou on s'y
perd un peu
finalement il faut aller sur plusieurs
sites alors il ya les deux il ya des
choses qui sont fort intéressants sont
tous ces sites il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont mis en oeuvre
et parfois c'est un peu déstabilisant
parce qu'on ne sait pas trop où aller
cliquer la ville cherche et on a
beaucoup d'informations en même temps
moi je pense que ça ne remplacera jamais
le contact humain quand on peut aller
dans une école mais c'est très bien que
dans cette année mais il ya quand même
cette possibilité au niveau des études
supérieures je pense que ça fonctionne
et que l'on peut
mais moi je pense toujours aux élèves
qui sont en fin de troisième qui vont
devoir être orientée pour les élèves qui
sont en seconde qui vont devoir choisir
spécialité m'a poussé accès ou qui
doivent faire des mini stages en
établissement sagnier pas c'est pas
parce que le faire en ville tu es donc
pour moi rien ne remplacera le contact
humain
c'est très important qu'il du bien être
mais il faut les deux je pense qu'il est
important on parler de l'orientation
tout à l'heure j'aimerais qu'on parte
sur 7
la réorientation pardon sur cette
thématique chaque semaine nous
interrogeons noté spectateurs sur la
thématique de l'émission la question de
la semaine c'est la crise sanitaire at
elle modifié vos choix d'orientation
c'est le nom chez nous qu'il emporte du
coup d'une courte tête mais à rennes des
pires ferry est ce que vous avez en
observer un glissement dans les volontés
d'orientation est ce qu'il ya des
métiers des formations qui attire plus
que d'autres où certains qui n'attire
beaucoup moins alors il ya deux choses
je dirais dans votre question il ya eu
l'idée de tanger un choix d'orientation
ça peut être aussi pragmatique la
première chose qu'on peut être de se
dire les conditions économiques changent
aussi dans la crise en lien avec la
crise ou qui payent droit une
orientation différente en fonction du
coût des études
écoute la venue en tant qu'étudiant
avoir un impact sur le choix est jeune
de 21 ans l'année prochaine
et la deuxième chose qu' il peut y avoir
des choix en fonction des thématiques de
formation vous se dire que
à l'aune de ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
et des inquiétudes que manifeste
notamment les élèves universités
exactions et je crois qu'on restions ça
aurait comme des bts ou vol ou une école
en fait on est elle effectivement la
colère devant des dispositifs qui sont
très performants il faut quand même le
dire
voilà donc s'est passé là pour les
domaines orientation ou alors on connaît
les grands domaines qui hâtif et qui
font briller les yeux des plus jeunes
le monde et même des étudiants
donc on connaît les listes c'est le cas
également en correspondance
mais aujourd'hui on passe les risques
majeurs également une ruse formation
étendue permet infirmiers auxerre qui
forme les futurs le piano et pour qu'on
cesse de tenter de le raisonner de
manière en observant en anticipant qui
les autobus ou en la personne de
l'accompagnement des d'autre part et
plus largement comme fond dans ce faire
les place en situation les services
outre les collectivités que les outils
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus du
petit c est ce que les habitudes et on
peut l'imaginer dans certaines dans une
certaine mesure
donc on va avoir besoin de temps pour
concevoir déployer aussi parce que
doublé du commerce reste actif ou le
domaine logistique de la livraison
quand on a vu que même le concernant un
fameux vaccin c'est être conscient
laetitia nico on a entendu plein de
pistes déjà
est-ce que
il y aura la question de l'éloignement
géographique on sait que le confinement
notamment le premier laissé beaucoup de
traces
actuellement des étudiants sont pas
seuls dans leur cité universitaire
est-ce que ça va être plus dur pour
certains
certains parents de laisser partir les
enfants loin sans la possibilité de les
voir régulièrement et de leur apporter
un soutien déjà deux sociétés des
changes alors tout parent est toujours
très triste quand son enfant quitte la
maison mais c'est notre rôle de parent
de rendre autonome notre enfant et de le
soutenir d'une manière différente si
notre enfant ait choisi de partir dans
une cité universitaire à 3 à lyon ou à
marseille
notre rôle par an c'est de le soutenir
le mieux possible c'est sûr que ce sera
compliqué vu que la pandémie
il ya des couvre-feux à 18 heures alors
on peut plus sortir on peut être moi
entre étudiants c'est c'est difficile
effectivement voilà je pense que c'est
difficile mais c'est notre rôle de
parent ou qu'on soit dans au quatre
coins du monde de rang 2 peut nous et
nos enfants est liée aussi on disait à
l'impact économique et y aura peut-être
plus de parents qui vont devoir aider
leurs enfants parlent financière non
parce qu'il n'y aura pas de job étudiant
ça c'est une réalité
effectivement oui ou qu'ils ne pourront
pas leurs enfants que je dirais parce
que si on tire le film jusqu'au bout en
réalité même un jeune qui travaille
durant ses études ou qui est boursier ou
qui reçoit des aides de sa formation de
son département et c'est parce qu'il en
existe une série quand même assez
importante
malgré tout la première personne qu'il
aide les premières places qu'il est ce
sont ses parents voir ses proches
donc si ces personnes là sont tractés
d'une manière importante dans l'exercice
de leur métier aujourd'hui il est
évident qu'ils aient des manières
habituellement on sait aussi que ce qui
la tire c'est d'aller étudier à
l'étranger on sait que pour le moment
passé les frontières françaises c'est
compliqué il y en a déjà 45% qui ont
relancé d'aller aller à l'étranger dans
les années à venir
est ce qu'on peut dire aussi que les
études supérieures vont changer de
visage aura moins de 2 de déplacement
des étudiants soit dans l'hexagone soit
dans les pays européens voir plus loin
vu l'attractivité quand même et aussi je
dirais
enrichissement que peut représenter le
fait d'avoir plusieurs étapes dans son
parcours que ce soit dans différentes
villes en france ou dans différents pays
dans le monde
je pense que ça reste quelque chose qui
sera couru la langue et culture okura et
à quelle échéance on pourra le faire à
nouveau
ça c'est une autre question mais
j'ajoute sur ce point que lorsque les
établissements qui ont donc des accords
échanges avec d'autres établissements
dans le monde ont quand même pu mettre
en oeuvre des cours à distance également
avec les partenaires donc comme on
disait tout à l'heure et le souligner
madame nico la présence la relation
humaine ne se remplace pas à travers un
écran mais néanmoins vous pouvez suivre
un cours en populaire - sagnol on a 10
ans et voir la différence de pédagogie
rendre des projets travail et
éventuellement en collaboration avec des
élèves et étudiants autre pays ça ça
peut quand même se faire à distance
l'expérience n'est pas la même et bien
justement on peut aussi apprendre à
travailler avec des gens d'autres pays à
distance qui se fait beaucoup dans les
entreprises
donc c'est aussi une mise en jambe sur
celui de collaboration outre sony qu il
faut garder il faut gagner
maintenant il faut garder espoir et les
échanges à distance à par internet c'est
intéressant mais aussi je pense que dans
l'avenir cette pandémie j'espère qu'elle
va disparaître même si c'est un peu dans
longtemps que les étudiants pour
repartir à l'étranger les riches ça
c'est cette culture à l'étranger c'est
aussi riches et très riches apporte une
classe dans le cv le curriculum vitae al
embauche aussi amd bien faire et on va
finir avec vous sur cette question les
candidats ont jusqu'au 11 mars pour
formuler leurs voeux il y a encore donc
un peu de temps
quels conseils on peut leur donner pour
les semaines à venir
alors on l'a dit depuis le début
interrogez vous sur vous-même interrogez
vos proches qui sont ceux qui vous
connaissent le mieux sur vos qualités
sur les deux domaines dans lesquels les
imaginerait
vous voir réussir ensuite quand je parle
des proches je parle aussi des
professeurs parce que même si on n'est
pas distant pour certains dans certains
lycées où la jauge des 50 % est
appliquée les professeurs sont toujours
à disposition et ils se posent et
surtout c'est aussi ça fait partie de
l'ambition de voir leurs lycéens devenir
des étudiants et donc ils ont de bons
conseils
on peut toujours se renseigner à
distance on l'a dit en trouvant de
nouvelles ressources sur des sites
d'information comme letudiant.fr sur le
site vit ces ihu sur celui de l'onisep
en se rendant sur des salons virtuels en
allant aussi sur à des journées portes
ouvertes si on le peut et puis bien
entendu sur parcours sur l'ensemble des
éléments de la phase d'information sont
toujours disponibles
c'est à dire que toutes les données que
vous aviez à disposition depuis un mois
ils sont toujours dont vous pouvez
encore découvrir les formations et puis
ensuite il faut faire des choix
voilà donc en fonction de toutes ces
interrogations il va vous falloir
choisir des cursus diveu et vous savez
vous avez des sous loin selon les
établissements
on va conclure sur ces mots c'est la fin
de ce sept huit sociétés merci de nous
avoir suivis merci à vous madame nico
madame des pierres furie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous pouvez revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
où notre application mobile on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau moment des changes
[Musique]